[Música]
destrucción y caos es el balance que
deja el paso de al menos 50 violentos
tornados y poderosas tormentas en siete
estados en el sur y medio oeste de
Estados Unidos donde casas negocios
árboles y autos Fueron arrasados por la
magnitud del evento Aunque este tipo de
fenómenos es difícil de predecir una
alerta temprana que salvó cientos de
vidas como la de esta familia en el
estado de Tennessee hicimos que los
niños se metieran en la bañera porque se
supone que es el lugar más seguro todos
nos encogimos porque las puertas Se
abrieron de golpe las puertas del frente
y todos los cristales de las ventanas
todo explotó al mismo tiempo al menos
unos 650 mil hogares se quedaron sin
electricidad durante el fin de semana en
los estados de Arkansas Indiana Illinois
Mississippi Alabama Tennessee y Delaware
en diciembre de 2021 unas 80 personas
perdieron la vida después de que otra
serie de tornados azotaran el estado de
Kentucky y hace tan solo una semana un
tornado arrasó Misisipi matando a 25
personas y causando enormes daños
materiales por lo que el presidente Joe
biden visitó el sitio y se comprometió a
que el Gobierno Federal se hará cargo
del 100% de los gastos de reconstrucción
en un intento por ayudar a las
comunidades más afectadas a recuperarse
cuanto antes
el viento comenzó a levantarse y a
levantarse y a levantarse y a levantarse
podía sentirlo toda la casa temblaba
entre tanto el estado de Texas se
encuentra en alerta máxima ante la
posible llegada de un fenómeno similar
común durante el inicio de la primavera